let's talk about robin d'angelo she is
one of the
premier pushers of critical race theory
and
that everything in america is based in
white supremacy and that we're all
racist and evil
and all of this other absolute drivel
nonsense and of course she herself is
white and you're not gonna believe this
guys
she's made a tremendous amount of money
telling white people that they're racist
she gets 30 grand
a pop for a speech i've given a lot of
speeches in my day i've never got 30
grand so
actually maybe i just need a better
agent or i need to
start talking to guilty white people i
talk to people regardless of the color
of their skin
and is what it is anyway uh this video
is from
uh my friend carlin borsenko she got
video of robin d'angelo
talking this is 2018
at a seattle public library a white
woman
talking to white progressives about how
racist
she and all of them are so
i'm pretty sure i'm speaking to a room
filled with white progressives
when i do a caucus group or something
and the white people are afraid i might
think they're racist
i think you're racist i do
because i think i am too right white
progressives can be the most difficult
for people of color
white progressives do indeed uphold and
perpetrate racism
when i first applied to be that
diversity trainer back in the early 90s
i
i thought well of course i'm qualified
to lead uh discussions on racism i'm a
vegetarian
and and let me just say that you know i
love seattle
and everything i learned about white
fragility i learned here working with
white progressives
so uh and this of course is the first
thing that tends to trigger white
fragility
generalizing about white people i i know
white people really well
i don't actually think uh young people
today are less racist
in fact uh they're getting worse so i'm
gonna i'm just gonna put it right out
here as a result of being born and
raised as a white person in this culture
i have a racist worldview
i have deep racist biases i have
developed racist patterns
lady get help i mean jesus you've got a
lot of problems
i'm not racist i don't care about the
color of anyone's skin i want everybody
to be treated equally
you obviously are racist your entire
world view your entire
ethos is a guilt around your own skin
color and then projecting that guilt
onto other sort of pathetic white
liberals and this is the biggest mind
virus eating western society
in 2020 in modern times she's bananas
that i i'm sorry look we've done four
stories today i talked about biden he's
got issues that's pretty obvious
joy reid she's a mental case uh uh
who is the other one oh robert i mean
this guy's got problems and then this
one but do you see what happens it's all
because these were once decent people
these were joe biden was once a decent
guy he really was a long time ago and
now he's compromised and marginalized
for many other reasons joy reid i well i
said i can't say that she was once the i
don't know enough about her
actually if you go back like 10 years
ago she had a lot of very very anti-gay
writing and a bunch of really radical
stuff so i can't say she was once decent
but reich was once kinda halfway decent
and this deangelo woman i don't know was
she always racist were her parents
racist were her grandparents racist
she would argue yes she would argue that
by the color of their skin they were all
racist
but these people who as gad said says
are just self-flagellating all the time
and whipping themselves and i'm so and
the way the audience
laughs i'm a white racist you're a white
racist
[Laughter]
what a world people what a world